[Music]
here's a tip guaranteed to make life all
a little more beautiful from artist
helen diltery you've got to watch this
a journal or a sketchbook is a really
good way to start sort of pulling these
things together and forming your own
styling getting to know yourself and
over time
you'll get used to doing something maybe
like a mood board
this is something that i begin before i
start any project and usually i'm
creating for a client or i'm doing a set
of paintings so it could be like eight
paintings and i know that before i begin
i really want to get my palette started
i want to get excited about what i'm
going to be painting so
i start gathering and i start collecting
and i start laying things down we're not
actually going to be painting any of
these things but we want to build a
foundation and figure out a color
palette and get inspired and the way i
typically work is by moving around the
board with color
and form
and just
placing things so that they please me
visually because i'm the only one seeing
this
and it's just so that when you come in
in the morning it gets you sort of
excited it gets you sort of the the
brain starts
sparking with ideas
i love helen chip and joanna where can i
get more of helen she hosts art in bloom
on magnolia network where she shares the
making of her beautiful original
creations i love it
[Music]